THEY WANTED HIM TO PLAY IN THE
LINEUP
THE PASSES PICKED OFF.
KIRBY BA
SHOT SAVED AND REBOUND AND
STILL 0-HEDMAN.
TOP OF THE CIRCLE AND ARE START
BUT THIS IS
IS GOOD TO GO. AND
RETRIEVED ALONG THE AND BALL.
>>.AL THAT CONNECTED
FOR A
ARE ABLE TO TAKE THE ZONE AND >
NICK PAUL STEPS AND OVER THE
BLUE LINENEIT IN THE LINE
AND SLAPS IT BACK IN THERE.AND
PRESSURE BY TAMPA BAY.
GOT THE PUCK BACK TO THE FRONT
THE NET.
ROSS COLTON GOING IN BEHIND
HE DROPS
AND BACK DOWN THE
CONCUSSIONS.
HITTING THIS GAME BACK ON AND
HE SAYS HE STILL FIFI
AND THE LIGHTNING HAVE THE PUCK
A LOT AND THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT CHICAG
>> HE IS NOT HAD THE PUCK VERY
OWN AND AND MISSED THE MARK CHI
LEFT EVEN THOUGH THE